-Our next guest is
a Grammy Award-winning musician
and songwriter and the front man
of the band Wilco.
Their album "Cruel Country"
is out now.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Jeff Tweedy,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Jeff.
-Hey.
-I want to start by asking,
do you remember this moment?
-No.
-No memory of it at all?
-It doesn't --
Is that --
Who is that, Bill Hader?
It's not Bill Hader.
He was just here.
It's Adam Scott.
-Oh.
Cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you worked
with Adam before.
You also worked with Fred.
-Oh.
-And -- Okay.
But this is a true --
Fred used to open for Wilco
doing stand-up.
-Yeah, I didn't know
he was gonna be here.
-Oh, okay.
Was it a weird vibe
back in the day?
-He owes my wife a lot of money.
-Oh, yeah.
So this is a --
You --
[ Laughter ]
This is true that Fred
made a promise to your wife.
-He made a legal document.
-Okay.
-Several times, we -- Yeah.
-And, now, what was the impetus
of Fred making this --
-My wife gave him his start
in show business
by allowing him
to answer the phones
at the rock club that she owned.
-Okay. This is true, Fred?
-True.
-Okay, and so in return,
what did Fred promise your wife?
-Initially, he promised 50%
of all of his earnings.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And then when she
confronted him, about it...
-Sure, as you would
if he didn't pay up.
-...he said he was sorry
and he would give her 75%.
-Got it.
And, now, you've actually
brought the legal document?
-I do have the document with me.
-Now, it is a video document.
-Yes.
-And, Fred, you will confirm
that you made this?
-Yes.
-Okay. Here is Fred.
And hopefully, if anybody here,
you know, passed the bar --
-I have my lawyer with me.
-Okay, great. Alright.
Let's see if you believe
this is a legal document.
-This is a legal document
without jokes,
without irony or sarcasm.
This is not an exaggeration.
I, from now on,
owe Susan Miller
75% of my income.
It used to be 50%.
It's up to 75%
because retroactively
going back to the amount
I owe her before,
I need to add to that.
That is all money brought in by
any comedy or any entertainment.
That is what's owed.
If you are a lawyer
looking at this,
there is no irony in my face
or, like, any winking.
I owe this money.
By the way, immediately.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I think
that's a legal document.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- Slam dunk.
-But Fred's
a little shady, though.
That's the problem.
Is it true that when Fred --
-How much could it be?
-10 grand?
-Something in there, yeah.
-Yeah.
-You've made probably around
12 to 15 grand.
-I would say 12 to 15.
-Yeah.
-So then you're getting
75% of that.
You're gonna do pretty well.
Fred -- Is it true that when
Fred used to open for you,
he would sometimes walk out
onstage and pretend to be you?
-Yes. Yes.
-Okay.
So the audience is there
to see you.
And what would Fred do?
-Fred would --
He would borrow my hat,
and I think he had a wig.
And he would borrow my guitar
and he would go out onstage
and just go, "Hi."
[ Laughter ]
"Jeff Tweedy.
I'm Jeff Tweedy."
And I think -- The sad part is,
I think a lot of people
really thought it was me
because -- I don't know.
I guess he's
a pretty good mimic.
-Yeah, he's a pretty good mimic.
-Yeah.
-I also want to see if I can get
confirmation on this from you,
that despite winning Grammys,
you had something that I
only thought existed in legend.
You had a Chipotle burrito --
free burrito card.
-I did.
-And so explain how it worked
and how you got it.
-I don't know how I got it.
-Okay.
-It showed up in the mail
one day in a carved wooden box,
like something you would see,
like, an immunity challenge
amulet or something.
And you opened it up,
and it said, "Jeff Tweedy's free
burrito card from Chipotle,"
and you would take it.
-Were you nervous the
first time you presented it?
-Yeah, I was a little nervous.
And it never --
it never got easy using it
because every single person
that you would hand it to
at the register would go,
"What the [bleep] is this?"
[ Laughter ]
And you'd go, "Just scan it.
Trust me, just scan it."
And they would scan it, and
they'd go, "What the [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
'Cause it would come up
100% discount.
-Wow.
-Celebrity discount.
-It would say
celebrity discount?
-100% celebrity discount.
So I'd buy burritos
for everybody in line
and for my children's school
and stuff like that, yeah.
-Did they know who you were?
-The people at the counter?
-Yeah.
-Oh, no.
-Okay.
-No, never. Never.
And so that would be --
The other half of the story
would be that a lot of times
we'd be sitting there eating
and they would be
back in the kitchen
trying to figure out who I am.
-Right.
-And unfortunately, one of
the main things that comes up,
I think, when you Google my
name, at least for a long time,
it has been me singing
Black Eyed Peas songs.
-Yeah, you did, like, a charity
event where you played.
-I did a charity event
for my friend Dan Sinker,
who made a book
about Rahm Emanuel
and the mayor race in Chicago.
And one of the bits
in his tweets
that he had done throughout
the campaign was that,
"That ass[bleep] Tweedy won't
do any Black Eyed Peas songs."
So he put together --
when he put out a book
of all of those tweets,
he asked me
if I would play a show
and do Black Eyed Peas songs.
So I said sure.
And I tried to do it.
It was out of --
It was not my skill set.
-Yeah. Do you mind
if we show a clip?
Because I was
very excited to hear
that you covered
Black Eyed Peas.
-Sure.
-You did -- I will say,
I thought it was
a beautiful match.
Let's take a look.
-Tonight's the night.
Let's live it up.
I got my money.
Let's spend it up.
Go out and smash it
like, "Oh, my God."
Jump off that sofa.
Let's kick it off.
[ Laughter ]
-Beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, so --
so they -- so they --
so everybody in the kitchen
would come out and want to --
"You're the
'I Gotta Feeling' guy."
-So wait.
So the Chipotle staff
then thought you were
in Black Eyed Peas.
-They thought I wrote that song.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's what would happen.
I mean, it happened --
It happened once.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for your honesty.
Thank you for your honesty.
-But yeah, because it happened
once, I can say it happened.
-Yeah, you can say it happened.
Yeah, legally you can
say it happened.
-But from that point on,
we just got stuff to go.
-Yeah, that's smart.
Yeah.
You don't want to put yourself
in that awkward situation.
-Just got out of the way
while they figured it out.
-Do you -- Are you ever
in a restaurant
where you hear your music?
-Occasionally, but I'm not --
I'm always the last one
to pick it out.
-Ah.
-I'll be like, "What is this?"
And my kids -- "It's you."
[ Laughter ]
-That must be
a weird moment for your kids.
They're like,
"What's wrong with you?"
-I think -- Yeah,
I think they're used to that.
[ Laughter ]
The card stopped working, too,
by the way.
That was an awkward --
That was an awkward day.
-Oh, my God.
Yeah. "Just scan it again.
Trust me."
[ Laughter ]
You're like,
"I'm a big-time celebrity."
-No, trust --
Just scan it again.
-Did you try multiple days,
or did the one day it stopped
working, did you let it go then?
-I went to a different Chipotle.
[ Laughter ]
Tried it again.
-That is a day
I hope you were on your own.
You didn't have your kids
with you.
Like, "Don't worry, boys.
It'll work at the next one."
-I was on the hook for a whole
restaurant full of burritos.
-Oh, no.
You promised it to the store
before you checked it.
You're like,
"Burritos for everyone!"
-Exactly.
The only times I've ever been
a big shot in a restaurant.
-Well, I'm very happy you guys
are gonna be out here
playing another song for us.
It's always such a joy
to have you here.
Thank you for making the time.
You guys, Jeff Tweedy.